Damn, he's cute. I pulled that yes, I
Want to wear this guy, but I know once I get my chair up
[whole] poem will be out, and that is not what I'm trying to give ya, [where's] my wheelchair
Adaptive skirt cuz I need to be comfortable oh
that is
Yeah, I gotta give them a little something since I have to be my chair the whole time. Where's that push-up, bra
Yeah, is it. Oh it is heels or boots
heels or boot Heels or boots
heels
I'm not walking in these bitches anyway, [whoo] okay?
It's 450 perfect the assist driver has enough time to put the chair together before he shows [up]
Which works because I can show my independence? Oh wait let me drop a pair to my besties
Safety first [did] I eat my mitt before I got out the car. I hold my breath don't [sting] wait
Oh my gosh, is [that] him oh, that's it. Keep it. You girl don't slouch
Strain your back put your phone away, girl. [oh]
He gets strong hugs [he] won't have any trouble caring me up the stairs when there's no elevator
[I] usually go for shorter guys, so they won't tell me in my chair too much
But I met at this tall drink of water
I'm just [glad] he's as cute in person as he isn't his photos you did that low
Ooh the chicken breast sounds good, but don't need his help cutting it should I ask him not too soon
I'll just get some pasta
John gill [I] have to lean in when he's talking. I can't sit back in my chair. I'll be too far away connection baby connection
You know I had a really good time today
Mm-Hmm. He's just as fine as he wants to be the lord took his time with him oh, I gotta say something
Yeah, it was it was really great. Yeah
I know you said [you] wanted to take the races today
But I don't mind picking you up if you ever decide to change your mind. Let me find out
Today, I need to get home before rides start to [surge]. Maybe I should let him take me home then nah
He can't have my address this soon. He helped break my chair down and put it in the car. [oh] he's so freaking cute
I can't wait till he getting this person
Oh, I'm a hot mess, but I'm just saying up got a hug and a kiss on the cheek super winning
He's definitely into you today was fun. I guess gentlemen do exist and don't mind being seen with me
Yes, um did it get it? [hey] Gonna get it up. Oh yeah
Ladylike is moving to our own new channel where you're going to find more of the great videos you love click here to subscribe